took office you've deliberately released
into the united states 836 000 illegal
immigrants who crossed our borders in
violation of our laws and sovereignty
how does this benefit americans
congressman if i can explain how the
legal
system works when encountering um
individuals at our southern border uh no
not always first of all that's not my
question when an individual is
encountered at the southern border they
are placed in immigration enforcement
proceedings okay
you don't have an answer for how any of
this benefits americans okay on and on
it went there this was a rough one
mayorkas there homeland security
secretary on the questions about the
border by administration insisting
they're effectively managing the border
that was the phrase he used california
republican tom mcclintock uh knows the
issue well was in the room and said good
morning to you good morning um
any headway any progress i'm in a couple
not a lot of answers
there won't be a lot of progress as long
as the people responsible for these
policies remain in office this is a
deliberate uh policy of this
administration to flood our nation with
illegal immigrants the 836 thousand that
they've already deliberately released
into the country that's larger than the
population of the state of north dakota
and while the border patrol has been
preoccupied with that influx six hundred
thousand god of ways have evaded
encounters and entered our country
illegally that is the population in fact
large in the population the state of
wyoming and that's with title 42 in
place when title 42 goes away they're
expecting 18 000 illegal crossings every
day that's like adding a new state of
alaska to our population
every 40 days and the simple question i
asked was how is it that flooding our
hospital emergency rooms with illegals
demanding care
packing our classrooms with non-english
speaking students making it harder to
deport uh criminal illegal aliens uh
flooding the labor market with cheap
illegal labor how does that benefit
americans i mean he has no answer
because it doesn't and there were no
answers to on the 42
who were in the country apparently were
on the no-fly list and
the terror watch list as well when he
said they've effectively managed the
border i think what he's talking about
is effectively managing the process
meaning when title 42 does go away and
you have 18 000 migrants showing up at
the border every day that they will get
them in the country faster i i i think
if you look at his report that's
essentially how they're explaining it
you agree or just that's that's exactly
right that's exactly right in fact i've
talked to a number of border patrol
agents on the border who've told me that
their instructions are to process as
many people into the country uh as
quickly as they can okay on this
disinformation board jackie heinrich
asking the question yesterday at the
white house uh in the briefing with gen
soccer i i don't really get it just yet
i don't think there's a lot of detail
that we know but i'll ask you on the
other side of this comment here
can you give us an idea of what this
board is going to be doing what their
authority would look like
sure jackie i really haven't dug into
this exactly i mean we of course support
this effort there's been some um
criticism of the person who's been
chosen to oversee this board sounds like
the objective of the board is to prevent
disinformation and misinformation from
traveling around the country in a range
of communities i'm not sure who opposes
that effort
and i don't know who this individual is
okay sir can you explain to us how you
understand it what is it who's on it how
do they work
it's a ministry of truth it is a
hallmark of any dictatorship and it's
antithetical to american uh principles
of freedom of speech
our entire democracy is based on the
free exchange of ideas in a free society
like ours you're allowed to express your
opinion whatever it is it can be hateful
uh stupid inaccurate
safe in the knowledge that as long as
there's a free exchange of of ideas
better ideas sounder opinions kinder
sentiments more accurate data will
always prevail but when you have a
government institution telling you what
you can and cannot say
you no longer have a functioning
democracy and that's where the left is
taking us that's where the left always
takes a society because they can't win a
debate in an open forum so they have to
suppress the opposition and you tell me
one place where the leftist sees control
where ultimately they haven't tried to
do that we'll see where it goes sir
thank you for your time tom mcclendon my
pleasure republican from california
thank you